[Music]
[Applause]
chris haynes oh our good buddy tnt
sideline reporter host of posted up
podcast with chris haynes the senior nba
insider for yahoo sports how you feeling
today chris
dp i'm all right i mean it's a little
frustrating watching those celtics um
over the last couple of games you know
just the way
yeah look you know i have no root
interest dp i i don't care i get paid
the same no matter who wins or loses but
yeah i do like to watch good basketball
and sometimes man just watching yourself
especially over the last couple of games
man it's just really frustrating but i'm
let's say somebody didn't watch the game
last night how would you sum up what
happened
turnovers that's what i was carelessness
um
just you know they're showing their
their lack of experience you know at
this stage i'm talking about the celtics
this just looks like a team that
it just looks like the stage is a little
bit too much for them especially when
the game gets tight it doesn't matter if
they're at home or on the road when the
game gets tight
they shrink
and it's frustrating like this this team
like they're throwing a ball
just just throwing cross-court passes
with no regard to who's over there a
teammate may be over there teammate may
not be over there it's just it's really
crazy how they've gotten to this point
and been able to you know be you know
they you could argue you can make the
argument that they've had the toughest
run to get to this point taking down
kevin durant kyrie irving giannis anto
kumpo the defending champion milwaukee
bucks then in miami heat and i was on
that series uh for the miami heat and
boston supplies for tnt and uh i think
miami just got really banged up jimmy
butler wasn't himself through latter
stages and
i think they might have caught a break
but god lee it's really frustrating to
watch this self-destruct it's high-end
talent but it's disorganized high-end
talent and i'm wondering
usually you have a point guard usually
you have
but marcus smart is not that guy
um and jason tatum
jaylen brown while they're high-end
talent
you know you kind of it's it's and
sometimes that's contagious the golden
state warriors made ball movement look
beautiful
when they first started it was like wow
extra pass all those things the celtics
don't have that capability they they it
feels like they're trying to be golden
state versus golden state
i think you know you definitely touched
on something dp when you talk about the
point guard situation i love marcus
smart um you know
he's the defensive player of the year he
does a lot for that team arguably he's
the heart and soul of that roster but
you know not having somebody who can
kind of set the tone and keep keep the
keep the offense going making sure
everybody gets into their sets and
getting to the right spot so they can
get quality shots that's something
that's lacking right now you know the
turnovers from jason tatum jaylen brown
and marcus smart are absurd you know
jason tatum and jaylen brown you know
while their handles are pretty they're
okay they got a nice tight handle but
when they're trying to penetrate in
traffic
they lose the ball they throw it away
like they have a difficult time trying
to penetrate
when there's somebody within arm's reach
and so it's you know i i you know we're
talking next year in the future what
they need to do moving forward but this
series man they just got to play smart
and that's just something they haven't
been able to do
how would you sum up the celtics defense
on steph curry and why he had an off
night hit historically bad off night
they were smothering him dp i was very
impressed on idea they definitely wanted
to clean that up off of the you know
historic game he had in game four um
coming off of those screens you know he
was clean off the screen robert williams
did a much better job in al horford in
playing up off of the pick-and-roll i
think they were sagging back too much
you and you can't do that stephen curry
you give him any type of space he's
going to make you pay stephen curry
didn't have those looks the problem was
they gave up
gave up looks on the other end to andrew
wiggins and to uh
and to um
pool yeah and so you know it was just a
tough situation i mean in dp not to get
back on the celtics again but i saw a
stat that i believe was by snap news and
it completely caught me by surprise
jason tatum
has had the most
turnovers ever
in a single post season
that right there
is cause for concern your best player
having that many turnovers you you can't
win that way yeah and i i think people
want to elevate him into
that it there's right i did i did okay i
did i was one of those i was one of
those guys i was one of those people you
know look i mean look at the run that he
had getting up to this point you look at
the fact that he's six eight
and can dribble the ball you know people
people say you know he's reminiscent of
um a tracy mcgrady type player but one
thing i've saw dp in his game is that
you know he has a tight handle
and you know i would say i would say
this to jason as well but
you know he moves when he's dribbling
the ball trying to get his shot
he moves east to west
he's like in his handles he's trying to
set up his jump shot he has a real
difficult time trying to penetrate go
nor go
go south get to the basket and
you know that's that's going to be
something he likes it he can get his
shot because he's 6-8-6-9 but is it
going to be a quality shot and then he's
having problems especially with um
andrew wiggins to get to the basket so
i'm seeing a lot of holes right now that
we just didn't see other teams um be
able to bring out but you know i was one
of those guys dp that was saying you
know
win the title um elevates them to
superstar status but you know even if
they are to win the title dp say they do
come back and win
um the next two
you know
i i don't know it's going to be up for
him up to him and jaylen brown who's
going to get the finals you know finals
mvp i don't know if his hands down jason
tatum so
there's a lot that we saw yeah and there
are two games left if you're a celtic
fan you hope there are two games left
and if they win game six back home and
then you go on the road and maybe has
one of those historically great nights
and they do win a title he's only 24. i
just thought the celtics as a team were
a year away and i think jason tatum is a
year away maybe from
joining uh
that rarefied air like the greek freak
luca
there's only a couple of those guys that
are truly great lebron
may not be in that you know group
anymore
uh just because your first team all nba
doesn't mean you're up there
where you take over a series
i mean
i think we we we were hoping he'd be or
maybe we were rooting for him to be
but at 24 that's a lot to ask and it
feels like the moment may be a little
too big for him
maybe these you know this game in boston
helps him but
if i said who is your mvp right now
though chris haynes from uh yahoo sports
i will have to go with
i mean
this is me people may hate me i'm not
giving my mvp award to a losing team so
even if steph probably i would look i
can't sit steph will have to go off just
have crazy crazy numbers and lose for me
to even consider him but as of right now
with golden state being up
uh he would be my finals mvp but andrew
wiggins
is not too far behind you know there's
still a lot of game left to be played
for anybody to have that award yeah i
had a
discussion with reggie miller yesterday
and he said he thinks steph curry even
if they lose is is the mvp now this is
prior to last night i said you can't
give it to steph if you didn't give it
to lebron
the year that andre iguodala got it
lebron was unbelievable you gave the mvp
to the guy whose job
sole job was to guard lebron
and lebron averaged almost a triple
double
you can't do unless the voters go you
know we made a mistake back then we're
not going to make a mistake this time
around
steph steph was wonderful in game four
he was not good last night
i have a hard time giving him the mvp
and a losing effort if they would lose
these last two games yeah i'm right
there with your dp and you know i don't
think i voted i can't remember i don't
think i voted that year that iguodala
got finals mvp but you know there's
there's still a lot of game left to be
played you know he had a great game for
um not so great game game five and
andrew wiggins even in game four he came
through big time for them down the
stretch and he was the best player of
game five so the the ward is up for
grabs but dp to your point about uh
jason tatum probably being on the cusp
and making first team all nba we got to
keep in mind the milwaukee bucks were
not whole keep in mind that los angeles
clippers were not whole we talking about
first team all nba and you know knocking
down the door you know kawhi leonard and
paul george they're going to be back i
think the lakers will be back to a
certain point i don't think you know i
don't think we'll see the same type of
season so you know these these moments i
i overheard some of the celtics when
they were walking out of the arena
overheard them saying man we got to
capitalize on these moments because you
think just because they're a young team
that they're going to be back yeah and
so they understand it like they
understand the magnitude and the
opportunity that they have
i just don't know if they can execute
for a full 48 minutes because they just
haven't shown it at all at all this
series they should be 3-1 up 3-1 in this
series you know they they they they're
shooting themselves in the foot
safe travels to boston thanks for
getting up early with us chris
dp for you i'll drink my coffee
and jump on here thank you anytime
brother that's chris haynes senior nba
insider for yahoo sports he was such a
gift to us during the pandemic
in the bubble he was wonderful
tnt sideline reporter and host of uh
posted up with chris haynes his podcast